KEVIN FEIGE
We've been waiting to tell the story
of Natasha Romanoff for years.
It was one of the great
post-Infinity Saga opportunities.
How to evolve into Phase 4.
NATASHA ROMANOFF
I'm done running from my past.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
Natasha is a product of all these films
that we've done.
KEVIN FEIGE
You will look at the past again
in a new light, and we are
sowing the seeds of new characters
into the future of the MCU.
NATASHA ROMANOFF
It's good to see you too, sis.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
Kevin's genius is that he thinks in this
really huge, unexpected way.
KEVIN FEIGE
You know a lot about the characters
already, so there are
presumptions that you bring to it.
YELENA BELOVA
Ok, you got a plan or shall I
just stay duck and cover?
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
My plan was to drive us away!
KEVIN FEIGE
And we like to subvert those.
YELENA BELOVA
Well, your plan sucks.
RACHEL WEISZ
Marvel's created something
absolutely extraordinary.
KEVIN FEIGE
We're excited for people to go to theatres
to see and experience this movie
in its place in the pantheon of the MCU.
NATASHA ROMANOFF
I made my choice.
I'm done running.